i think you'll get it
[Music]
yes
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
uh
good
everyone
hope you guys are doing well
okay so it is very chilly today
oh my goodness i don't know what
happened but yesterday i woke up this
morning and it was like 30 degrees
weather and i can't take this check and
check it off to save my mind
so i hope everyone is doing well
welcome to the table we are thrilled
that you are all here uh those of you
who are joining us online as well you
are very much a part of this community
and we love that you're able to join us
virtually
i'm gonna try to be quite
[Music]
um so we are um having our
uh
christmas eve
uh service this friday uh so it's gonna
be at 4 30 um that's here
it will be live stream so those of you
who are joining us online who are more
than welcome to participate that way
but this is a family family uh kid
events so all the kids are welcome to be
in uh be part of this we will have
nursery that that evening
but all the kids will be welcoming part
of that
as well
um just a couple other things
let's see
oh yes the following saturday uh sunday
we are kind of taking off just gonna
give everybody a little bit of a break
um it kind of helps with our leadership
all of our volunteers everything like
that just kind of take the following
sunday just kind of like a quick
rest
um so we'll be presuming our normal
schedule on january the 2nd so just kind
of apparently you know where that but if
you're dying you have to be in a church
um that sunday uh
with that being said i am going to start
us with prayer and we're going to get
started with worship
lord thank you so much for just bringing
us together
thank you for
um just the ability to be here
to be in this room to be
here to listen to tune in
and to just open our hearts and minds to
what you have for us this evening
i pray you um just
be with us be able to help us to connect
with
with your word
connect with you in song and in spirit
and christ and i pray amen
thanks don
well guys we are small but we are strong
when he surrounds us right
um
all right i have been reflecting a lot
this week on just kind of that uh
that unique thing about the nativity
story and the coming of christ and how
and brett's kind of talked about this in
the series how we have that kind of
anticipation that longing for the thing
that's coming but it hasn't come yet you
know and i was thinking about like even
throughout the bible it's not even just
in the nativity story but looking back
on um
like when the egyptians were persecuting
the people of god and they were waiting
for their savior to rescue them you know
what i mean or when joseph was
waiting for god to deliver him and he
was in that whole process where his
brothers had thrown him out you know
it's over and over we can see these
stories where people are waiting for god
to show up
and in our lives in my life there have
been times there are times where we are
waiting to see when god is gonna show up
and what the answer is gonna be
so um in just kind of that spirit and as
we build up into this week of christmas
um i have sort of this itch in me
sometimes that likes the sad movie or
the sad song
or the thing that's not quite resolved
like i have this special place in my
heart for it and if you guys will just
indulge me that's how we're gonna start
this service um so listening to the
words of this carol i just feel like it
fits right in with that whole spirit of
we are waiting for jesus to come on the
scene
um and let that be kind of a posture of
your heart where we're acknowledging the
our own places where we're waiting for
him to show up waiting for the rescue
and being honest with him and that and
seeing where he wants to meet us
because he will meet us he will find us
he is our messiah and he is coming he is
here with us he is god amongst us
so um if y'all would like to stand up
and join us in this carol um there may
be some words here and there coming in
that it's in you know parts of the song
that are new that we just kind of worked
together to create so you might not know
them as we go into them but as you hear
them more i just encourage you guys to
join in sing out we will probably hit
wrong notes so it doesn't matter if you
hit them as well we're all in it
together all right
so all right caitlin's going to get us
started tonight
[Music]
oh come on
here
[Music]
disperse the gloomy
clouds of night
and death dark shadows
rejoice
[Music]
is
rejoice
[Music]
see rejoice rejoicing
you will
shall come to thee always
[Music]
jesus you're the one who saves us
constantly creates us
into something new
jesus surely you will find us surely our
messiah
we'll make all things news sing that one
more time
jesus
you're the one who saves us
constantly creates us
into something new
jesus surely you will find us surely our
messiah
we'll make all
[Music]
things new
my soul cries out
my soul cries out for me
these bones cry out
[Music]
you
can raise the dead
my soul cries out
my soul cries out for you
see jesus
jesus
you're the one who saves us
constantly creates us
into something new
[Music]
jesus
you're the one who saves us constantly
creates us into something new
jesus surely you will find us
[Music]
we'll make sure
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh oh
[Music]
we
chose we
chose
[Music]
rejoice rejoice
amen
[Music]
shall come
rejoice rejoice
amen
you will
shall come
[Music]
thank you guys
we're going to move into our prayers of
the people so you guys please offer
whatever is on your heart when we get to
that portion of the prayer and if you're
online please join us by leaving your
prayer in the comments
jesus for this city of saxi and for
every city and community and all those
who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for prisoners and captives
and for all who remember and care for
them
we pray to you
because lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
from online
nancy's chemo
those grieving the loss of a loved one
safety for those traveling over the
holiday prayers for megan
for mandy
and for nancy's keynote
[Music]
charles
from online
prayers for heather
[Music]
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
in jesus name
[Music]
who's my heart
fears
[Music]
i am yours
i
[Music]
am here
i am
[Music]
is
is true
let's speak this truth of us
[Music]
foreign
speak what is
[Music]
speak what is true
scott
thank you that
you are present among us that you did
come
to rescue your people god
[Music]
and by your people i am speaking of a
world that was in need
both from the poor to the rich
from the shepherds to the kings
[Music]
from every nationality
and every economic status
and everything in between god you've
come to rescue us
jesus would we experience that this
christmas
would we wait and long for you
would we look for you to show up in our
life in the places where we've
experienced disappointment and pain
would we keep looking for our savior
and finding him in every moment
the unexpected
the frustrating
the beautiful
the sweet moments with our family and
the moments that give us stress and
anxiety god when we find you
there with us present in our pain and in
our joy
we love you god and thank you for who
you are in our lives
thank you for coming and would you speak
to us tonight as we listen
it's in your name i pray amen amen
all right if you guys want to turn and
welcome the people around you as we get
started brett's going to bring us our
message
everyone
grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all on this
uh this sunday before christmas it's a
special time of year and um
um yeah i'm just glad that you all could
could be here that of course always
includes those joining us online we love
you a lot and um and anyone who's new
here or just kind of you know still
feeling like you're plugging into the
community um i know that can be
i don't know just kind of a stressful
difficult process at times um and and i
just want you to know you know we really
long to be
um even though we're well let me kind of
preface it by saying we are far from a
perfect church that is for sure true
um if you've been here any length of
time you know that but um you know we do
long to be inclusive um
just
really regardless of um
well just of all people you know whether
it's around race or gender or sexual
orientation or um
political persuasion
theological outlooks you know like at
the end of the day are we're kind of
just banking on the fact that our shared
love of jesus
will somehow keep us
together and bonded to one another in
love you know that's kind of what we're
just banking on that so um
all that to say i hope you do feel just
i don't know a sense of welcome and uh
and hopefully the peace of god here man
i think we just need more of that in our
world don't we like in our own hearts
and minds
um
so i'm grateful for spaces like this
where we can come and just kind of be
present and
tune into god in a in a new way it's
really really cool
so um before i jump in i do want to also
just mention um and kind of encourage
you to invite either a friend or a
family member or someone to our
christmas eve service that'll be like
don mentioned that'll be coming up on
friday and um i think it'll be a really
beautiful service i'm quite excited
about it as we've been you know prepping
and planning and all that um and so you
know who knows like how god uses that in
someone's life it may can seem just like
a simple thing like a text or you know
whatever um but who knows what god does
with in in their own hearts and heart
and mind and 2022 and beyond like who
knows so i just encourage you um feel
prompted to to go ahead and reach out to
someone all right so we are in this is
uh part four
fourth and final
part of our series titled wonder
making room for advent
and uh like mindy was mentioning earlier
advent is it's really a season of
preparation and longing for christmas
for
um god to come among us god to show up
in our in our world um and
and for christ to kind of show up in our
own heart and mind you know to be
transformed from the inside out to live
with a sense of of god's presence and so
advent is kind of uh
preparing for that you know what would
it take to live into that vision um so
that's kind of what the series has been
about um
so the title of my message uh specific
to tonight is
promise
question mark
and uh our text is gonna be from luke
chapter one uh verses 39 through 45. um
before i go in and start reading it all
i should mention that this whole um
kind of passage it's an interaction
between two women um elizabeth and mary
this is the of course mary that is
connected with the christmas season uh
mary mother of of jesus and so elizabeth
is her um
relative
and we don't know the exact relationship
um i mean maybe like an aunt you know
you would think if it were her mother
like the text would say that instead of
just saying you know a relative so
something like that we do know elizabeth
is much much older than mary um she's
described as like a very someone much
later in years so um so we know there's
that kind of dynamic but apparently
they're quite close um
so and just for a little bit of context
so basically the angel has
just appeared to mary has given her the
news you will bear god's son you know
you will name him jesus you will save
the people from their sins it's like the
the whole kind of moment
and then we come into verse 39 at that
time
mary got ready
and hurried to a town in the hill
country of judea
where she entered zachariah's home
and greeted elizabeth zachariah is
elizabeth's husband
and greeted elizabeth when elizabeth
heard mary's greeting the baby leapt in
her womb and elizabeth was filled with
the holy spirit in a loud voice she
exclaimed blessed are you among women
blessed is the child you will bear
elizabeth said
but why am i so favored that the mother
of my lord should come to me as soon as
the sound of your greeting reached my
ears the baby in my womb leapt for joy
blessed is she who has believed that the
lord would fulfill his promises to
her
is that a beautiful passage uh you can
tell
elizabeth is uh
she's pumped it's all the exclamation
marks you know that gives it away it's
all these but you don't get a lot in the
bible it's a pretty the bible's pretty
chill book honestly like it'll just say
the craziest most intensive things it'll
just kind of be like oh yeah that
happened but this is one of those
moments that's just exclamation mark
exclamation mark blessed are you blessed
is your child blessed i mean she's just
like she's kind of freaking out she's
very very pumped and you know i say like
rightly so
um because i think she's starting to get
an intuition through you know it talks
about how she's filled with the spirit
like she's getting this this kind of um
connection with god and she's um kind of
seeing ahead and she's understanding
that i mean god has wrapped himself in
flesh and come among us
divinity has touched humanity
in
i mean what is it it's really the most
clear and powerful way that we've ever
seen
uh as as philippians 2 actually puts it
um the christ who
um
was in his very nature god he did not
count equality with god something to be
grasped something to be held onto and
possessed instead
god emptied himself taking the form the
very nature of a servant and being found
being made in the likeness
the image of who
you
and me
he humbled himself he emptied himself he
poured himself out he who was everything
became
nothing
for our
sakes
and now he is emmanuel
god
with
us
and and so elizabeth she intuits this
she sees it
and she's
she's pumped and that's why she says
mary like three times she says it mary
you are blessed
blessed are you blessed is your child
blessed is she who has believed that the
lord would fulfill his promises to her
and and so the question that's going to
drive our my message tonight is um it's
about that closing line what i'm kind of
what came to me is
why does she close with that like why
all of a sudden is she talking about the
promises of god and blessed are you
married because you believe you believe
the promises of god like why in this
kind of spirit inspired kind of
prophetic moment she's like speaking the
word of god to mary why close with that
line blessed is she
who has believed that the lord would
fulfill his promises to
her
so to get the answer to that you need
you need elizabeth's whole um her whole
back story
so
like i mentioned elizabeth
was and she was an older woman and in
that culture
a woman's whole identity
her her
place in the social order it was really
bound up with having children
uh for a man it was different a man's
um place in the social order and that in
the ancient world was to um to provide
and to protect
you know go to work produce
and protect if need be go to war and
that was like the man's kind of role and
then for a woman though it was very much
tied it was just tied in with the home
it was having children it was raising
them up
and that was like
that was just the world and of course i
mean to some degree that's still kind of
true you know every culture kind of has
its gender norms and such
and um that's kind of still true in our
in our world or our modern times but
i'll just say it's not quite as intense
as it was back then
like back then
it was
real intense uh probably some of this to
be you know charitable um i think some
of it was was just the fear people lived
with
um you know just surviving
was kind of a big deal
you know and it was a very um
we tend to think of this in kind of a
very negative sense it was very tribal
um but
you know tribes cut both ways tribes can
be good and that it provides a sense of
connection relationship identity um
the the downside was you know like in
the modern world we're like very into us
as individuals like individual freedom
you know and but you know but that's a
trade
right the stronger the individualism the
the the weaker the tribe and the
connectedness right and this is kind of
a real struggle in the modern world is
worse so and i'm an individual i've got
my own path my own dreams my own rights
my own goals you know that the kind of
the tribe sort of flounders and we're
kind of like rootless in a way um
they didn't have that problem they just
had other problems
right so on the upside they had a tribe
oh you had a people
oh for sure you had people in your life
a whole community some of the the
challenge though was because that you
had these very strict kind of gender
norms and because the tribe is trying to
survive
the idea is basically like hey
um play your part
play your role everyone has a role to
play and we're all getting in line
you're like well i'm an individual you
know like in the ancient world it was
like
no
you know that was just not a thing it's
like you've got a role play your
role
and so
um you know for the man again it was
kind of produce work
wage war if need be for the woman it was
um have children this
and then raised them up that was sort of
um
that's how you found your your place in
the hierarchy the better you were at
that the higher
up you were in the social order
um so
the thing is
um
if you're all familiar with elizabeth's
backstory
then you know that up to this point she
had lived a somewhat
i don't know kind of a miserable
existence
because uh
although she had a good marriage her
husband zachariah he was a priest
um
you know so they're like good
churchgoing couple um serving in the
community involved in the temple
um
although they did all the right things
up to this point
elizabeth
even though she was you know way along
in years now she had never had uh never
had a baby
never had a child
and so for not not months not years but
decades
she had just begged god
just please
like please why
why
why me
why me why
why or really why not me
like why not me why can't i do this
thing like this is my whole world and
identity like this is
everything everything god and the one
thing like the one thing i need to do to
like have my life begin
and here she is you know
it's like time's just passing her by
you had that moment you know where
you're praying the prayers and they just
bounce off the ceiling
you know you ever had that anyone ever
had that moment that's elizabeth just
for decades the prayers are just
bouncing off the ceiling and ricocheting
right back on her
that is
until
um
six months before the moment we just
read about in verse 39
six months before mary
barged through that door
six months before then
um
[Music]
an angel appeared
to actually not elizabeth interestingly
enough but to her
husband
zechariah
um
and
it's it's interesting so the zechariah
he was in the temple
doing his priestly thing when suddenly
an angel appears to him
and says zechariah
your
your wife's prayers
have been heard and have been answered
she will bear a son
you will name him john
and
you know what zachariah said well let's
say let me go with what he didn't say he
didn't say amen
hallelujah oh my gosh i'm so grateful i
can't believe it like no you know what
he said
how can i be so sure
that's what he said it's in the bible
how how can i be so sure he said i am
old
[Music]
he's just being honest i am old my wife
is old
how can i be so sure i love the angels
response
he says uh
i am gabriel that's what he says that
was his name i am in other words
do you know who i am like guy with wings
floating off the ground like i am
gabriel he says i stand in the very
presence of god
and god sent me to tell you
this news
but since you have not believed me
you will not say another word
until the day your son is born
and right then zachariah just he's like
it's gone
can't speak
[Laughter]
now
um what this is where my imagination
kind of went this week i started
thinking like
what do you think it was like for
zechariah to go home
right he's finishing up work
heading back up but i mean this is like
a day of old days i mean and it's such a
conflict right because on the one hand
this is amazing
amazing news remarkable like this is the
prayer it's been the prayer for 70 years
like oh my gosh it's happening and but
he can't
he can't say anything i'm just imagining
he like gets home what does he do is it
like a charade thing is he like acting
it out is he maybe he's a priest so
maybe he could write i'm imagining he
because somehow he has to communicate
right to elizabeth like oh my gosh so
i'm just imagining he busts through the
doors
i guess he grabs parchment pin you know
something he's like trying to write out
and elizabeth what is she doing she's
probably just like what
zachariah what is going on
say something to me what is i am
freaking out right now and i'm yeah i
guess he just had to write it out like i
was there i'm in the temple and angel
appeared to me it's like you're gonna
have a baby you and your wife and i'm
like i don't believe you and he's like
well fine i'll give you a second miracle
you won't say any more words and i guess
he just had to like write the whole
thing out
and
uh this is how
it plays out like can you imagine a more
kind of bizarre
moment in
in human history
so that's the backstory
that's the backstory
so fast for six months
elizabeth is pregnant
has been for six months just as the
angel
said
um now she's kept it to herself
has not told a soul
when suddenly she hears a
boom boom
at the door
in walks mary
we look again this is verse 41
when elizabeth heard mary's greeting
the baby leapt
in her womb
and elizabeth was filled with the holy
spirit
so in that moment what happened
elizabeth kind of just she also she
through the spirit she knows everything
she knows mary's whole backstory cause
remember the angels appeared to marry
too
she knows the whole backstory but i
think that's not the most important
thing what's the most important thing
what's the i think it's the opening line
when elizabeth heard mary's
greeting
do you see the connection
elizabeth heard mary's greeting why does
that matter remember zachariah did
elizabeth
hear
zachariah's greeting
after his angelic visitation
no
but elizabeth heard mary's greeting
you see here's the point i think
elizabeth
had first-hand experience
with someone
who was given a beautiful gift from god
but they could not receive it
he could not receive it
i think in a similar way you and i we
can be given a beautiful gift from god
and yet be completely unable to receive
it
because you see elizabeth knew
what time
and disappointment
in bitterness
and fear
fear of what family will think fear of
what the neighbors will think
fear of getting my hopes up again only
to have them dash to the ground
like she knew what time and
disappointment and fear can do to a
person
she knew firsthand
that you can be so wounded and jaded
that gabriel himself
can show up in your room
and say
i have good news for you god has great
gifts and plans for you you can be so
wounded and jaded that you will respond
not with a
may it be unto me as you have said
that's what mary said
but with a how can i be so
sure
elizabeth knew this first
hand
but elizabeth heard mary's greeting
and in that moment
what does she know
she knows that mary
did not miss the time of her visitation
she knew that mary
had heard
and believed
and received the gift
of god
and that's why she says oh blessed are
you dear girl
blessed are you blessed is she
who has believed and received the
promises of the lord
blessed hughes believed that the lord
would fulfill his promises to
her
blessed are you mary
unlike
that man
in the back room
right now mary
[Laughter]
zachariah who has not believed the
promises
of the lord
friends don't let past disappointment
erode your capacity to receive a
beautiful good
gift from god in the present
don't let it happen
don't let past disappointment and pain
erode your capacity to receive it
see because to be fair
i do think um i think mary had one
potential advantage over zachariah
one advantage
mary was young
and perhaps
perhaps life had not yet kicked her in
the teeth
kicked her when she was down i mean
maybe that's
some of what i mean obviously we don't
know mary's backstory maybe it was super
hard for her
but maybe not
maybe she had that young
trusting
like
god is good all the time all the time
god is good you know
just that trust and it's like because
maybe just maybe she hadn't like really
suffered
she hadn't had the decades
of just broken heartedness but that's
the thing zachariah knew
like zach right he was a broken man
just years decades of of just a sense of
disappointment
like god's not answering the prayers
of feeling like a failure even if he
wasn't a failure but he
probably feels like it right he's not
living up to the social expectations and
and what happened it just eroded
and what's crazy is like i mentioned
zechariah was a priest
he's a priest right i mean to put it
crudely like he was in the god business
he should be awesome at this
right
but that priest
well i'll tell you hey i'm i guess a
part of that group
it's it's easy to um to be in the to put
it crudely god business and i'll use
that term a lot but you know what i mean
and um
to have your heart broken
and to
even
there's i mean pastors even who lose
their faith in god entirely
in fact some of you sometimes the more
you love
and the more you try
and the more you pray
and the more you put yourself out there
like it's a double-edged sword on the
one hand you have the moments of victory
you have the moments where god comes
through
it's like amazing and sometimes people
are like we love you thank you you know
like that you have that
and you get your heart broken
and sometimes the prayers go unanswered
and sometimes it feels like god is so
distant
and you see the suffering right you get
like the back door looking at people's
lives and it's like
there's a lot of pain
and what can happen
it just
erodes
just erodes i love that word because
it's slow
right this isn't about a cataclysmic it
just falls apart in a moment that's
almost never how our faith in god
dissipates
it just
erodes away
don't let past disappointment
erode your ability or capacity to
receive beautiful gifts from god in the
present
don't let it happen
be like mary
be like mary who just keeps trusting
stays gentle
stays open man what could god do with
the church of people
who as we get older because hate to
break it to you none of you are getting
any younger
none of us are
but what could god do with a group of
people who the older we get
the more we trust
the more open we become
the more trusting of god we become
the deeper our faith goes let's do it
let's do it let's be those kinds of
people are you with me
people what could god do with a group of
people like that i mean i know there's
no way no i don't have millions of folks
here
but i think god could do something real
special
i mean at the very least in our own
hearts and minds that would be a win
just i mean heck i would love to be in
ministry for 40 years and not get bitter
you know like that would be a huge win
like for me at the end of the days to i
love god even more than when i started i
will take it
you know and i pray that same thing for
each of you
you know like that would be a win just
to say i love god i love others like
more than when i started
i mean that could that could change that
will you just get folks having that step
that would be a big win so let's do it
let's do it i want to i want to close
this it's sort of a it's not really a
prayer it's kind of a
exhortation blessing
prayer
thing i'm not sure what it is but i want
you to i do want you to receive it so
you can go ahead and close your eyes but
i do want you to open up your hands if
you're comfortable with that go ahead
and just kind of open up your hands
and i want to speak this this over you
the older you get
may the deeper your love and trust go
until at the end of your days may you be
like mary
blessed
because you believe the lord blessed
because you lived with trust blessed
because you said may it be unto me as
you have said god
he who has begun a good thing a good
work in my life god will be faithful to
complete it
and so refuse
all
bitterness
refuse all fear
refuse all resentment
and instead
believe
and just as importantly
receive and live the promises of god
blessed are you
who has believed
that the word of the lord
his promises will be fulfilled
in the name of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
amen
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do it
next time i'm gonna go for it
well this last song is really just in
that same spirit of acknowledging that
uh
we
need jesus
to heal us in the areas where we need
healing so that we can receive
the gift that he has for us
um so let's just
pray this
together as we're as we're leaving
i've
carried a burden
[Music]
too long on my own
i wasn't
[Music]
to created
it alone
i hear your invitation
to let it all go
and i see it now
i'm laying it down
and i know that i
need
you
so i run to the father i fall into grace
i'm done with the hiding no reason to
wait my heart needs a certain my soul
needs a friend
so i run to the father and again
you saw my condition
had a plan from the start
your son for redemption
the price for my heart
and i don't have a context
for that kind of love
i don't understand
[Music]
i'm done with the
again and
again and again
[Music]
again
long before my first
[Music]
is
your mercy is calling
out
just as i am
you pull me in
and i know i need
[Music]
i'm done with the hiding no reason to
wait
my heart felt
[Music]
oh
and again
[Music]
oh goodness thank you all for just uh
being with us here tonight um
just a quick reminder again about our
christmas eve um
service that's going to be here at 4 30
this friday i don't want you to miss
that out
um
if you um if you're visiting uh we would
love for you to be able to fill out a
well a visitor card that's you can find
those on the table that's right there
through the doorway uh also if you would
like to support our ministry as well
there's a box also outside on that same
table where you'll be able to
do that um
and then of course after service i will
be up here if just anything that you
need prayer for um or anything that
might resonate with you as well um just
be able to love to be able to stand with
you in prayer
i do want to send you guys out in with
this prayer
so
uh lord i just want to just thank you so
much
uh just for
just being in your presence
being able to hear
about um
the divine appointments that might be
you have waiting for us this next week i
pray that you help us to be remain open
have our hearts our minds just attune to
where you want us to be
and receive those blessings
in christ saying right amen
[Music]
running
deep in my chest your
[Music]
just as i am
you pull me
[Music]
my soul found a friend
again
[Music]
again and again
again
[Music]
you didn't have to stay the whole time
is
[Music]
i should have just looked over